madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce dimanche 18 mars
le mystère autour de la disparition
d'une française à londres la jeune femme
âgée de 29 ans n'a plus donné de ses
nouvelles depuis une semaine maintenant
un avis de recherche a été lancé par la
police britannique
dimanche politique à cinq semaines du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle nicolas sarkozy a réuni
dix mille jeunes au zénith à paris
ségolène royal parle pour la première
fois d'une vième république
et puis marie george buffet est notre
invité ce soir quatre ans de guerre en
irak avec l'heure des bilans et des
questions comment le pays peut-il se
sortir de cette guerre civile et puis
que reste-t-il aujourd'hui des projets
américains de paix dans la région
c'est un sport qui demande des capacités
acrobatiques
incroyable le speedflying vient de
naître une dose de ski extrême ajouter
une dose de parapente images à découvrir
tout à l'heure enfin cinéma avec la
sortie mercredi de golden door
l'histoire des migrants qui ont fait le
choix de l'amérique au début du 20e
siècle
un film avec charlotte gainsbourg un
avis de recherche a donc été lancée à
londres afin de tenter de retrouver la
trace d'une jeune française michelle wie
l'imec à 29 ans elle travaillait comme
serveuse dans plusieurs bars de la
capitale britannique
et cela fait maintenant une semaine que
personne ne l'a revu son téléphone ne
répond plus c'est son ex petit ami
inquiet qui a alerté la police
maryse burgot dans les rues de
twickenham des appels à témoin placardé
par la police
michelle wie l'imec 29 ans est française
elle est installée en grande-bretagne
depuis six ans elle a disparu depuis une
semaine
elle vit dans ce quartier tranquille et
plutôt chic de la capitale britannique
ce couple de retraités lui loue une
chambre à l'otage que la police anglaise
a perquisitionné à trois reprises cette
semaine que sa brosse à cheveux pour
avoir des échantillons d'adn et m
oui et tout ce qui peut aider aussi la
police scientifique
c'est une femme réservée au parcours
assez chaotique travaille comme serveuse
dans ce pub
nous y avons rencontré son ex compagnon
très inquiet il n'a pas souhaité être
filmé il a lui-même donné l'alerté à la
police
les enquêteurs ont été confrontés en
2004 au meurtre d'une autre jeune
française
ils ne font aucun lien entre ces deux
affaires mais ce précédent ajoute à
l'inquiétude
dans le passé il lui est arrivé de ne
pas se rendre à son travail mais de
disparaître complètement comme ça sans
prévenir personne
ça ne lui ressemble pas et ça m'inquiète
doute
michelle wie l'imec a été aperçue pour
la dernière fois dimanche dernier chez
ce marchand de journaux fait je le femme
semble avoir très peu de familles en
france les enquêteurs vont simplement
localiser sa grand mère elle a déclaré
elle aussi être sans nouvelles de sa
petite fille depuis plusieurs jours il
était 16h30 hier après midi lorsqu'une
voiture s'est engagée à contresens sur
l'autoroute a21 près de lens le véhicule
conduit par un homme de 86 ans provoque
alors cinq accidents impliquant
finalement une moto dont le conducteur a
été tué l'octogénaire a été mis en
examen ce soir marianne masse et de
dominique maes ils étaient deux sur la
moto le conducteur un homme de 42 ans
père de cinq enfants est grièvement
touché il n'a pas survécu à ses
blessures
il est décédé hier dans la soirée sa
passagère sa femme elle est encore
hospitalisé dans un état très grave
le drame s'est produit hier vers 16
heures alors qu'un automobiliste s'était
engagé à contresens sur l'autoroute a21
à bord de sa clio en quelques minutes
il causera plusieurs accidents matériels
impliquant quatre véhicules dont les
conducteurs parviennent à l'éviter en
allant s'encastrer dans les rails de
sécurité ou les murs et au bord de
l'autoroute
arrive alors cette 206 rouge qui tentent
de s'écarter fait un tête à queue et se
retrouve sur la trajectoire de la moto
qui l'a percuté de plein fouet le
conducteur à l'origine de ces accidents
un homme âgé de 86 ans a expliqué aux
enquêteurs qu'il s'est vite rendu compte
qu'il roulait à contresens et qu'il
essayait d'aller le plus vite possible
pour se sortir de l'autoroute présenté
cet après midi au juge d'instruction il
a été mis en examen pour homicides et
blessures involontaires
son permis lui a été retiré on a une
nouvelle fois frôlé la catastrophe au
large d'ouessant un chalutier du
guilvinec a été victime d'une collision
avec un porte conteneurs qui a poursuivi
sa route
victime d'une voie d'eau le chalutier a
finalement pu regagner le port avec son
équipage
le centre de secours et de sauvetage
aurait identifié le navire soupçonné
d'être à l'origine de la collision
caroline gauthier ils l'ont échappé
belle
quatre marins étaient en mer à bord de
ce chalutier au large d'ouessant en
pleine nuit un navire a heurté leur
bateau ce matin il raconte la violence
de la collision
oui et je suis tombé de s'étendre et ma
couchette mon équipage bareille le bloc
était car lui il a été balancé contre le
côté monde s'est fait un peu mal comparé
par méchamment mais bon le chalutier
perd tout son matériel
à l'arrière la cale à poisson très
abîmée se remplit par chance les câbles
du train de pêche se rompent le
chalutier ne sombre pas sur la
passerelle
un marin pense avoir identifié ce porte
conteneurs le velasquez sous pavillon
britannique commence la lutte mameui
devaient malgré souvent ils viennent
tout près et puis manoeuvre papa au
dernier moment mais bon jour le navire
est criminel devrait atteindre dublin
dont la soirée il sera soumis à une
inspection des collisions comme celle ci
se produit souvent dans la rade doux et
sans très fréquenté la fin est
généralement plus tragique pour les
équipages en janvier 2006 5 m'a rendu
klein family disparaissent en mer après
collision avec ce chimiques le sichem
pandora le cargo maltais avait poursuivi
sa route sans s'inquiéter du sort du
bateau de pêche quatre ans de guerre en
irak et des manifestations un peu
partout dans le monde pour protester
contre l'invasion américaine des
cortèges pacifiste que l'on retrouvé aux
états unis mais également en corée du
sud en espagne ou encore en grèce
une journée marquée sur le sol irakien
par de nouvelles violences contre
l'armée américaine huit soldats ont été
tués ce qui porte à clous 3200 le nombre
de gi's tués depuis le début du conflit
quatre ans de guerre donc et des
questions qu'a apporté cette
intervention américaine la chute de
saddam hussein mais quelle est
aujourd'hui l'avenir de l'irak
enfin le pays pourra-t-il éviter la
partition j rabin fait le point sur ce
conflit
quand la première bombe américaine tombe
sur bagdad dans la nuit du 20 mars 2003
le président de george bush a ignoré
toutes les mises en garde
il a décidé de redessiner la carte du
moyen-orient et d'en finir avec saddam
hussein rien ne peut l'arrêter
la suite semble lui donner raison après
seulement vingt jours de combats l'armée
américaine entre dans bagdad devant
l'impôt vide de trois hommes sans chef
vident leurs derniers charger george
bush crie victoire
en réalité la vraie guerre commence
d'abord contre l'occupant américain
ensuite une guerre de terreur aveugle
d'attentât à la voiture piégée ou de
kamikazes
derrière laquelle très vite on devine al
qaïda et ben laden les victimes sont
d'abord des civils des solitudes et
chiites riches issus des sceaux need et
touche le fond au don de l'irak et de
l'islam
soudain une énorme explosion
la panique
la cavalcade affolé pour survivre
commence alors la guerre de tous contre
tous une guerre civile qui ne dit pas
encore son nom
avec des bilans effrayant 20 morts
chaque jour fin 2003 puis 30 50 80 plus
de 100 morts par jour depuis l'automne
dernier aux états unis le cap des mille
soldats américains tués au combat n'a
pas provoqué trop de débats en revanche
le cap des 2000 soldats tués passent mal
dans l'opinion américaine
la capture de saddam hussein n'a rien
changé ni son procès ni sa pendaison
le référendum sur la nouvelle
constitution irakienne et les
législatives qui ont suivi n'ont rien
changé non plus quatre années de guerre
l'histoire d'un fiasco militaire
politique diplomatique et morale
le scandale de la prison d'abou ghraïb
les prisonniers torturés humiliés et
avis il s'appelle justin danica 22 ans
originaire du texas il est le 3000e jia
est mort en irak quatre ans de massacres
et de chaos et aucune sortie crédibles
de conflit ni d'espoir de paix à
l'horizon
l'irak toujours où deux millions de
chiites se sont rendus aujourd'hui en
pèlerinage à la jack au sud de bagdad à
l'occasion de l'anniversaire de la mort
du prophète mans mais les pèlerins qui
selon la tradition chiite se sont auto
flageller vous le voyez sur ces images
et pour éviter tout attentat suicide des
milliers de policiers étaient déployés
dans toute la ville l'arrestation de
cesare battisti l'ancien activiste
italien d'extrême gauche était en fuite
depuis 2004 il a été interpellé au
brésil
battisti avait été condamné à perpétuité
en italie pour des homicides commis à la
fin des années 70 réfugié en france
durant près de quinze ans il avait
disparu alors que la justice italienne
réclamé son extradition karine comazzi
jean yves blanc il avait choisi de se
perdre dans la foule pour échapper à
l'extradition et à la prison à vie en
est à lui la cavale de chézard et
battisti après pain ce matin sur cette
plage à rio ils étaient surveillés
depuis sept mois par la police française
il est 8 heures une femme venue de
france s'apprête à lui remettre 9000
euros lorsque la police brésilienne
intervient battisti n'est pas surpris il
donne son identité
il est conduit à la police tu verras
battisti la personne qu'il ya des
espèces effectivement ont été
interpellés par les autorités
brésiliennes cesare battisti est
actuellement sous écrou extraditionnel
tandis que l'autre l'autre personne a
été remise en liberté très rapidement
l'ancien activiste d'extrême gauche a
fui l'italie ziem 26 ans il y est
condamné à perpétuité pour quatre
homicides perpétrés au nom de son groupe
les prolétaires armés pour le communisme
il trouve refuge en france où françois
mitterrand protège les anciens
terroristes qui ont renoncé à l'action
violente les en 2004 la droite au
pouvoir revient sur cette promesse après
une bataille judiciaire baptiste est
déclarée extradables lorsque nous
l'avions rencontrée nous avait confié
son incompréhension des leaders le
gouvernement italien se dit satisfait de
cette arrestation tout comme cet homme
qui a perdu son père et l'usagé de ses
jambes dans un attentat attribué à
battisti que cet homme qui nous dit ce
soir qu'il est satisfait que battisti
soit condamné à la perpétuité
le comité de soutien de chez art et
baptiste y est sous le choc
l'extradition de battisti du brésil peut
prendre six mois mais à son arrivée en
italie l'ancien activiste sera placé en
détention à perpétuité sans nouveau
procès un dimanche une nouvelle fois
très politique à cinq semaines du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle nicolas sarkozy avait
choisi le zénith à paris pour assembler
dix mille jeunes le candidat de l'ump
qui a proposé la mise en place d'un
grand plan marshall de la formation pour
tous les jeunes des quartiers
nicolas sarkozy qui a réaffirmé vouloir
rendre à chaque jeune français la fierté
d'être français
sur place le reportage d'alix
bouilhaguet et jean-marc new look
exit le chanteur didier barbelivien
il était pourtant un habitué des fins de
métier face au jeune nicolas sarkozy a
dépêché un autre jeune faudel et son
nouveau tube mon pays
il
mon pays le ton est donné car de la
france il en a été beaucoup question à
la tribune
encore une fois nicolas sarkozy plaide
pour son ministère de l'immigration et
de l'identité nationale puis des
décennies nous nous excusons d'incarner
une identité nationale républicaine et
française je n'ai pas peur de vouloir
défendre l'identité de la france de la
république et de la nation
nicolas sarkozy comme les yamakasis et à
cette banlieusarde cultive l'art du
déplacement un pas à droite un pas à
gauche
histoire de prouver que lui aussi peut
parler d'amour de fraternité de ses
faiblesses aussi des blessures des
épreuves je sais qu'avec la voix que je
me suis choisie et l'ambition que je me
suis fixé
j'en connaîtrai d'autres mais ce risque
pour moi il vaut mieux que celui de ne
rien vives de ne rien éprouver aucun
sentiment fort aucune passion
ce lavoir aucun projet aucune ambition
donc un rêve si la salle est acquise à
sa cause dans les rangs beaucoup
s'inquiète du phénomène bas il avait un
mélange qui est patrick roy qui est
intéressant aussi
mais je pense que c'est trop et et
reviennent pour confirmer qu'il creuse
et bien bayrou bayrou pas ségolène royal
mais bayrou pensé que je pourrais être
au deuxième tour oh oui martin solveig
le dj à la mode fait danser et sarkozy
tu as faim semaines du premier tour
nicolas sarkozy doit encore montrer
qu'il faut s'adresser à toute la
jeunesse de france de son côté ségolène
royal avait rendez vous avec les élus du
parti socialiste à la porte de
versailles à paris elle a tenu à leur
rendre hommage en affirmant je sais ce
que je vous dois
elle leur a fixé une feuille de route
pour la campagne parlant pour la
première fois ouvertement d'une vième
république françois bonnet eymard et
cazaux ils sont venus tous les ténors du
parti socialiste c'est d'éléphants
vis-à-vis desquels ségolène royal avait
affirmé vouloir reprendre sa liberté
sont au premier rang
alors dès les premières secondes de son
discours changement de cap
je sais ce que je dois à mon parti je
sais ce que je dois aux militants devant
5000 maires conseillers généraux
sénateurs ou députés
la candidate socialiste parle de sa
réforme institutionnelle et pour la
première fois elle lui donne un nom
c'est le 6ème république
elle est prêt et lorsque nous l'aurons
réussi grâce aux votes des français dans
un référendum populaire
alors oui ce sera notre sixième
république et 7 à celle là que je vous
invite et c'est celle ci que le fonds
perd ensemble
françois hollande lui a pour mission de
concentrer ses tirs sur les autres
candidats contre françois bayrou son
arme
c'est l'ironie je pensais qu'il avait
été ministre de balladur de juppé qui
avait mis un million et demi de
personnes dans la rue mais je devais
théâtre anneaux le meeting s'achève sur
une autre première la marseillaise à la
porte de versailles dans ce lieu cher à
la droite ségolène royal aura donc voulu
rassembler son parti et même au delà
ségolène royal qui n'a eu que quelques
pas à faire pour se rendre au salon de
l'étudiant situe également aujourd'hui à
la porte de versailles de paris où
visite apparemment improvisé en raison
de la présence de françois bayrou
les deux candidats étaient d'ailleurs au
même moment dans les allées du salon
mais ils ne se sont pas à croiser
morceau bayrou qui lors de cette visite
s'est prononcé pour la création d'un
grand ministère rassemblant les attentes
de la société française véronique saint
olive et guillaume michel nous ont
suivis aujourd'hui cerné pressé
bousculer françois bayrou prend quand
même sont en cinq heures au salon de
l'étudiant pour écouter discuter avec
les jeunes études problème espoir
bonjour
ce magnifique ce que vous faites à tous
il répète que l'avenir de la société
dépend de leur formation un pays comme
la france si on a les jeunes les mieux
formés de la planète on gagnera la
mondialisation
les poteaux s'ils venaient en soi bayrou
joue la proximité à la chirac il parle
aux jeunes de leurs chances repoussent
leurs peurs évoque des lendemains qui
chantent
rien que du positif c'est un candidat en
tête qu'ils pourraient
marquer le changement nous aimerions que
vous veniez donné une conférence à la
sorbonne
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d les petits
contre un dc et les coudes riom que vous
vouliez rallier à votre bain très bien
merci mon pays je vous prie et qui fait
essayé de me tuer ça c'est l'âme de
tubes récents compare par rapport à fin
d'études à ségolène ségolène n'est pas
crédible et sarkozy est un manipulateur
donc aller bayrou et françois bayrou
renvoie dos à dos ses adversaires qui à
gauche comme à droite at il eu recours à
jamais formé une majorité les français
ils pensent que c'est à pleurer et que
précisément parce qu'ils sont dans cet
enfermement
dans cette volonté de d'exclusion et de
rester entre eux les français vont les
renvoyés à leurs chères études
c'est une oeuvre d'art françois bayrou
sait qu'il doit encore séduire et qu'on
veut être des jeunes qui ne croient pas
aux étiquettes et aux partis politiques
mais qui ont besoin de faire confiance
l'invité politique de ce journal
maintenant elle est députée communiste
de la seine saint denis maire du
blanc-mesnil elle a été ministre des
sports de lionel jospin est à l'abri
pour la première fois à l'elysée je
reçois ce soir marie george buffet
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'abord une petite
question
elle se passe comment cette campagne
vous la sentez comment elle est longue
elle est dure elle est difficile est là
non il n'est pas difficile parce que
partout les hommes et des femmes que je
rencontre sont sur les sujets essentiels
l'emploi la santé et l'école et donc
qu'ils cherchent à voir si une autre
politique est possible et donc c'est
vraiment tout à fait passionnant de
pouvoir témoigner qu on peut faire
autrement dans l'autre pays
il qu'on peut répondre à ses grands
problèmes alors vous présenter sous
l'étiquette gauche populaire anti
libérale pourquoi avoir abandonné le
sigle parti communiste france que nous
avons travaillé depuis 2004 un
rassemblement de la gauche de toute la
gauche d'ailleurs nous ne sommes pas
pour la petite gauche le cartel des
gauches que voulons rassembler tous les
hommes et les femmes de bord qui se sont
prononcés par exemple pour le non de
gauche au référendum de 2005 et nous
voulons continuer ce travail et c'est
pour ça que j'ai pris cette appellation
de gauche populaire et antilibérale
alors arlette laguiller et olivier
besancenot peut-être josé bové
d'ailleurs vous souhaitez qu'il est sa
signature demain josé bové savez ça
c'est un problème de parrainages mais
j'ai envie de dire c'est pas ça
l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est tous ces hommes et ces
femmes menacés de licenciement
aujourd'hui ses fins de mois qu'on
n'arrive pas à boucler parce que les
salaires sont trop faibles cette
précarité qui envahit toute la vie y
compris la vie des jeunes nous avons
besoin de convaincre le même électorat
qu'arlette laguiller qui fait la
différence
justement mais justement je trouve qu'il
faut se rassembler à gauche et arrêter
de multiplier les candidatures des cèpes
en fait un appel à un rassemblement oui
bien sûr parce que les sondages le
montrent la gauche est très basse la
bouche très bas sont et la droite c'est
pas possible la droite de nouveau gagné
cette élection et les questions
législatives donc il faut se rassembler
à gauche mais il faut se rassembler sur
un programme qui permet aujourd'hui de
changer vraiment la vie quotidienne j'ai
envie de dire aux gens à arrêter de
penser l'étions comme si on était déjà
au second tour essayez de penser les eti
en pensant à vous essayez d'émettre un
vote utile pour vous c'est à dire pour
votre emploi pour l'école pour la santé
ça veut dire vous répondra dominique
voynet qui propose aujourd'hui de se
réunir justement toutes les forces de
gauche a fait appel
avoue d'ailleurs pour écrire un
programme quelque chose en commun on a
élaboré un programme avec les collectifs
antilibéraux moi je suis prête à
discuter et à débattre avec toutes les
forces de gauche bien évidemment c'est
mon souhait j'ai voulu d'ailleurs hors
réunir toutes les forces de gauche pour
par exemple avoir une riposte commune
sur la sphère d'airbus pas seul il me
semble est c'est important hélas le
parti socialiste a refusé
moi je sois et quand vous aurez sûrement
que ségolène royal désoriente le peuple
de gauche ça veut dire quoi
bah écoutez pour l'instant on sent bien
que la candidate désignée comme la
candidate officielle de la gauche ne
porte pas un projet capable de dynamiser
de fidèles enthousiastes mais les hommes
et les femmes de bourges moi c'est le
sens de ma candidature c'est de faire en
sorte que l'on ne fasse pas du beru vis
mais comporte vraiment une politique qui
permette de changer la vie si elle
figure au second tour vous la
soutiendrai écoutez moi je pense pour
second tour il faut toute la gauche se
rassemble quel que soit le candidat de
gauche arrivé en tête
et parce qu'il faut pas qu'à droite
parce que je veux pas que monsieur
sarkozy qui s'est adressé aux jeunes
tout en ayant soutenu le cpe tout en
étant mieux traiter les jeunes de
racailles soit président de la
république donc je pense qu'il faut unis
font soigner renault plus parce que
françois bayroux c'est un homme de
droite
je suis député je les ai vus agir
pendant ces cinq ans je sais c'est un
homme de droite dont il faut absolument
pas que la droite il se rassembler à
gauche au second tour alors justement
une chose étonnante l'électorat
populaire ouvriers et plus séduits par
nicolas sarkozy ou alors s'abstient ou
par jean marie le pen que par vous
comment vous l'expliquez bien parce que
justement il faut je pense que la gauche
porte un discours qui soit beaucoup plus
fort par rapport aux droits des salariés
dans les entreprises par rapport à l'
question des salaires c'est pour ça que
je propose aux semis de 1500 euros par
rapport à l'accès à la santé ces
terrains et c'est le sens de ma
candidature c'est de montrer que à
gauche il n'y a pas qu'une gauche du
renoncement
il ya une gauche du courage il combat de
chiffres 3 27% c'était le score de
robert hue lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle en 2002
aujourd'hui vous êtes à 2,5 pour cent ça
vous inquiète
et moi je navigue pas avec les sondages
lui navigue avec eux les hommes et les
femmes que je rencontre savez je parle
pour la france je vois toutes ces
ouvriers ces ouvriers menacés
licenciement je me bats avec eux et pour
eux et je me bats pour qu'un
gouvernement de gauche façon sans que
soient plus les prédateurs financiers
qui dirige le pays
merci beaucoup moins
une d'un journal merci beaucoup nous
vous parlions la semaine dernière d'un
village breton qui avait choisi de se
mobiliser contre l'expulsion de 23 de
leurs habitants 23 sans papiers malien
qui travaillait depuis cinq ans dans un
abattoir de la commune depuis deux
d'entre eux ont déjà été envoyées à
bamako mais alors que sont devenus les
autres le point avec romuald bonnan et
fabien delory dans le village breton de
6000 habitants depuis trois semaines
toutes les occasions sont bonnes y
compris le match de football dominical
pour soutenir la cause des 23 habitants
d'origine malienne des sans papiers qui
vivait ici depuis cinq ans pour la
plupart et qui sont aujourd'hui sur le
chemin de l'expulsion
en trois ans j'ai jamais eu un problème
mais que bon nous on comprend pourquoi
ce qui leur arrive l'on comprend port et
depuis leur arrestation personnes à
montfort sur meu n'accepte leur absence
alors ici jour après jour la solidarité
s'organise pour marquer l'attachement à
ces maliens connu de tous
la situation des gens ce ne sont pas des
dossiers ce sont des hommes
ça fait cinq ans qu'ils sont là et qui
vivent en haut mais maintenant ils ont
constitué les familles à renfort de
manifestations toute une commune qui ne
cesse de réclamer de la part de l'état
de l'indulgence pour ces maliens venus
travailler dans cet abattoir avec de
faux papiers au départ mais avec un vrai
contrat de travail un travail que leur
employeur espère leur redonner au plus
vite
pourquoi s'apercevoir bout de 4-5 ans ça
pose des drames au niveau de
l'entreprise d'hyper des bons salariés
des gens déboulent à montfort qui
vraiment qu'ils perdent des amis ils
abreuvaient quelques bas depuis que
certains ont été expulsés d'autres
placés en rétention quelques-uns se
cache quelque part sur le territoire
avec la peur de ne plus revoir leur cité
bretonne c'est quelque chose m 1
qui est produire pour nous quelle était
la barre mais avant dé ces problèmes là
donc on s'était bien comme les offrandes
des maliens de montfort sur meu a bien
décidé de ne jamais se séparer le
cerveau vous le savez reste encore l'une
des dernières grandes énigmes de la
science pour aider la recherche cette
semaine avait lieu la campagne du
neurodon
les fonds collectés permettront de mieux
comprendre les nombreuses maladies du
cerveau et notamment la dyscalculie une
pathologie rare qui handicape les
enfants pour les calculs mathématiques
explications nathalie sapina mathias
secondes un cran diviser car nîmes 2 par
0,5
une opération qui exige de geoffroy
beaucoup d'efforts donc tout est des
lignes ont conclu me voir en commencer
car il souffre d'un trouble de
l'apprentissage des maths
cela s'appelle la dyscalculie
quelques savoirs méchant toujours sur
mes doigts comme la dyslexie
la dyscalculie frappe des enfants à
l'intelligence normal mais incapable de
jongler avec les chiffres lui faire
faire énormément énormément de
l'addition soustraction et il connaît le
mécanisme par réflexe mais il ne
comprend pas à quoi ça peut servir
décrypter ce qui se passe dans le
cerveau de geoffroy et des 5% d'enfants
atteints de dyscalculie c'est l'objet de
l'étude menée par des chercheurs belges
qui scrute la matière grise de 40
volontaires de 11 ans à l'aide d'une irm
la bosse des maths c'est dit
steen ancien théorie mais qu'a fait que
l'utilisation de nouvelles méthodes de
neuro-imagerie revient tout doucement
car cette ip l'irm le montre très
clairement il y à bien une zone à
l'arrière du cerveau activées par le
calcul c'est le sillon intra pariétal on
le repère très bien chez l'enfant bon en
maths l'enfant dyscalculiques lui
utilise moins cette zone
il fait appel à d'autres régions du
cerveau navx pourquoi et comment
corriger cela pour l'instant des
questions sans réponse mais tout l'enjeu
de ces recherches c'est d'arriver un
jour à trouver des méthodes efficaces
pour permettre à ses enfants s'il faut
le découvrir les joies du temple le
salon du tourisme ferme ses portes ce
soir et parmi les tendances de ces
dernières années voici une illustration
du tourisme solidaire de plus en plus de
tour opérateurs proposent des séjours
pour venir en aide aux populations des
pays en voie de développement
voyons si ces vacances sont finalement
vraiment utile éléments de réponse avec
caroline thébaux et virginie travers
souvenirs de vacances en afrique ce
touriste a choisi de s'imprégner de la
culture locale mais aussi et c'est
compris dans le séjour de donner des
cours d'informatique
voilà une forme de tourisme solidaire
une immersion de plusieurs semaines dans
un village avec pour les plus motivés de
l'aide au développement
ça viendra hamid a alors fui la ville
avec les enfants qui sont sur place ce
n'est pas une réunion d'organisations
humanitaires mais bien une agence de
voyages ces touristes se préparent à
partir au moins un mois au bénin dont
trois semaines utile budget entre 2000
et 2004 sans opposition c'est cette
implication auprès de la population qui
à mon avis vaut la peine et qui
nécessitent gvt qui justifie les
finances la plupart des gens en fait ont
déjà eu l'expérience dans le bénévolat
dans dans l'aide associative en france
extrait où ils ont envie d'aller d
ailleurs mais la plupart du temps les
ong notamment spécialisée recherche les
gens qui ont ce qu'ils vont s'investir
sur 6 mois 1 an + tout ce qu'on propose
c'est une alternative
une alternative qui laisse sceptiques
certaines organisations humanitaires
les métiers de l'humanitaire ça reste
des vrais métiers en tant que tel qui
nécessite des compétences importantes et
donc il ya quand même une frontière
évidente et tout le monde peut pas
s'inventer humanitaire ou spécialistes
de développement du jour au lendemain
la plupart des voyageurs n'ont pas cette
prétention se sont d'abord de vacances
explique cette informaticienne et de ses
cours de français
elle dit avoir autant appris que les
enfants les deux parties sont gagnantes
moi parce que j'ai pu rencontrer des
gens formidables et puis euh parce que
j'ai pu leur apporter une petite brique
dans la découverte du monde qui les
entoure en trois ans le concept se
développe aujourd'hui cent mille
voyageurs français ont adopté le
tourisme solidaire
c'est le week end de la saint patrick le
saint patron des irlandais la tradition
veut que tout le monde parade dans les
rues habillés en vert petit tour de ces
célébrations de paris à moscou en
passant par new york et dublin
évidemment florence griffon
bienvenue à la fête de la saint-patrick
un événement planétaire est d'abord très
vert aux couleurs de l'irlande et du
printemps accessoire indispensable le
trèfle à trois feuilles saint-patrick
l'aurait utilisée pour expliquer aux
irlandais la sainte trinité
c'est lui qui les a convertis au
christianisme mais pas forcément assez
grand chapeau à dublin
ils étaient près de 500 milles à battre
le pavé au son de la cornemuse à new
york
le froid n'a pas découragé les membres
de la plus grande communauté et landaise
du monde de se retrouver à chicago c'est
une tradition
même la rivière était de la fête
à paris forcément c'était plus petit
mais tout aussi chaleureux et arrosé
preuve que les celtes ont converti le
monde à leurs coutumes
même les rues de moscou ont été gagnés
par de jolis irlandaise en costumes et
de drôles de géant vert à l'expression
plus limité la page sports de cette fin
de week-end avec les débuts fracassants
de ferrari en formule 1 la revanche est
le titre de champion du monde de jean
marc mormeck en boxe la victoire au
finish d'un espagnol dans le paris nice
et puis du football avec le match
auxerre lens images commentées par
julien moment en formule 1 reprise des
hostilités
heureusement sans danger c'est ce qui
s'appelle coupé la route
kimi raikonnen lui réalise le sans faute
le finlandais nouveaux pilotes ferrari
ont ramené du début jusqu'à la fin
au téléphone michael schumacher
maintenant à la retraite le félicite à
londres au champion du monde antique
passé chez mclaren termine 2e hamilton
complètent ce podium est créé la
surprise à 22 ans
pour ses débuts en f1 déception en
revanche pour renault ce le physique et
la sixième marque des points
pour voir la france brille et direction
levallois perret avec jean marc mormeck
des lourds légers wba et wbc le
guadeloupéen a pris sa revanche face à
eaunes el baile un jamaïcain roublard
avec lui sékouba livré en troisième
ronde
mais aussi directe qui sonne après le
gong
un match qui s'est poursuivie jusqu'en
conférence de presse pour mettre les
choses au point
o'neill belle et salaires pouvoir
disputer la belle dans le paris nice la
victoire de l'épreuve s'est jouée dans
la septième et dernière étape alberto
contador grâce à son échappée à 22
kilomètres de l'arrivée remporte
l'épreuve
le premier français sébastien joly
termine 12e enfin auxerre s'impose à
domicile face à lens grâce à kahlenberg
en début de rencontre
une victoire qui permet aux auxerrois de
denim place et fait rechuter lance le
dauphin de classe la volée skis en
alternance voilà les maîtres mots d'un
nouveau sport le speedflying il s'agit
de mélanger de discipline pour n'en
faire qu'une du ski extrême et du
parapente la première compétition avait
lieu aux arcs manuel tissier guillaume
fautrat
les amateurs de sensations fortes n'ont
pas de limites voici l'une de leurs
dernières trouvailles glisser sur les
skis et voler sous une voile cette
semaine 26 pionnier du speedflying se
sont donné rendez-vous à 3200 mètres
d'altitude au dessus des arcs la
première compétition officielle de cette
jeune discipline réservée aux gros coeur
on a quand même les vingt meilleurs
mondiaux donc c'est des gens qui passent
à les 300 jours par an sous une voile de
parapente
on a des champions du monde de
parachutisme donc les gens savent ce
qu'ils font c'est pas des cascadeurs
encore une fois ils se font plaisir et
ses voix lasse et c'est le fun avant
tout le speedflying grimpe en flèche au
hit parade des sports extrêmes montré
certaines écoles de ce qu'ils ont
inscrit à leur programme
mais près du sommet de l'aiguillé rouge
ce n'est pas une affaire de débutant en
moins d'une minute
ces skieurs oiseaux dévale la face à
plus de 80 km
le pilotage prime sur les qualités de
glisse mais le mariage de l'air et de la
neige suscitent de belles poussées
d'adrénaline
ce qu'on recherche c'est surtout la
vitesse et puis jouer jouer avec le clos
relief vous avec la pente à haute
vitesse
et puis quand il ya des belles parties
comme ça ben essayé de rester au sol de
larguer d'un parapente le grand
vainqueur de cette compétition est un
spécialiste du vol mais le lit jean
albert s'est illustré dans une autre
discipline 106 en voile il plane seul au
dessus des montagnes
c'est fou volant n'ont vraiment pas de
limites
c'est le printemps du cinéma comme
chaque année l'opération propose des
places à 3 euros 50 pour toutes les
séances jusqu'à mardi soir
un tarif unique attractif qui avait
attiré l'année dernière 2 millions 600
mille personnes plusieurs acteurs ont
parrainé l'opération
dany boon ou encore antoine de caunes
étaient présents cet après midi à la
défense à paris cinéma justement avec la
sortie mercredi de golden door
l'occasion retrouver charlotte
gainsbourg elle tient ici le rôle d'une
jeune est bien mystérieux anglaise qui
choisi d'émigrer en amérique au début du
20e siècle
un film à la fois émouvant et drôle que
nous dévoile pascal deschamps et
frédéric de la rue
l'histoire on la connaît des millions
d'émigrés en route vers le nouveau monde
un mois de traversée
quelle aventure avec golden d'ordre
embarqué avec votre baluchon et vos
espoirs
embarquez avec salvatore mancuso un
paysan sicilien parmi tant d'autres oui
mais cette amérique parce qu'elle reçoit
de ses cousins d'amérique des cartes
postales où l'on voit des oignons géants
et des arbres à dollars la famille
mancuso quitte sa terre et fait le grand
saut
un saut dans l'inconnu j'ai été frappé
par les volières les uns des grands
photographier dès leur arrivée ils
regardent l objectif avec un air
suspendu herbe et incrédule
comme s'il venait toujours mais comme de
débarquer sur la lune sous la halle où
l'un sur le bateau salvatore élit son
destin à celui d'une jeune anglaise
mystérieuse parce qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'elle fuit ensemble ils découvriront
non pas une amérique de cartes postales
mais une amérique qui sélectionne les
nouveaux arrivants ellis island
pas seulement pour rejeter les malades
mais aussi les idiots rien que ça par
une batterie de tests
je pensais que comme dans le parrain bon
quand on avait une maladie on avait une
croix et puis on été placés en
quarantaine mais qu'après on rentrait
quoi qui avait pas de qui avait pas de
tri c'est affreux chose
on dirait du tout
cochet
bien des maisons très grand golden door
où la force des rêves sur une histoire
qu'on croyait connaître un film plein de
fantaisie d'humour de poésie qui flirte
avec fellini
une pure merveille mais voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo nathalie rihouet
à 20h50 le maître du jeu à 23h10 france
2 rend hommage à lucie aubrac en
diffusant le film de claude berri avec
carole bouquet pour trouver demain à 20h
david pujadas belle soirée à vous